HAPPY FRIDAY MY FRIDAY FRIENDS.
WHAT A GREAT SHOW WE HAVE
TONIGHT.
I SAY THAT EVERY NIGHT.
EVEN WHEN IT.
IT'S A COPING TRICK THAT I
PICKED UP FROM THE HOST AT FOX
AND FRIENDS.
THEY DON'T WATCH, WHAT DID THEY
KNOW?
HERE IS A FUN SURVEY AND BY FUN
I MEAN IT AGREES WITH ME WHO IS
NEVER WRONG.
A NEW POLL CONDUCTED BY POLITIC
WHICH IS SPANISH FOR VOMIT.
CHOSE AT THAT MOST HISPANICS
ACTUALLY LIKE THE TRANSPORTING
OF ILLEGAL ALIENS INTO LEFT-WIN
SANCTUARY CITIES.
THIS ACTION ONLY UPSETS WHITE
LIBERALS AND SANCTUARY CITIES
WHO ARE FORCED TO BE
COMPASSIONATE INSTEAD OF SIMPLY
PRETENDING TO BE.
THERE ALSO KNOWN AS LATE.
>> MY APOLOGY WHO PERFORM A
VALUABLE FUNCTION.
MAKE FUN OF THEM ALL YOU WANT,
BUT IF HE DID NOT HAVE ONE, I
WOULD HATE TO BE YOU.
WHERE AM I?
BUT IF THERE IS ONE THING WHITE
LIBERALS ARE GOOD AT IT'S BEEN
CREDIT.
THAT AND TELLING ME THE SPECIALS
.
IN THE SURVEY THE QUESTION WAS
WOULD YOU CONSIDER SENDING
MIGRANTS TO US STATES TO BE
APPROPRIATE OR INAPPROPRIATE?
FOR HISPANICS AND SET
APPROPRIATE THAT SAIL BY A
SIX-POINT MARGIN WITH A
PLURALITY OF 41 PERCENT.
A PLURALITY.
I THINK WE CALLED THEM A DAY.
ONLY 35 PERCENT SAID
INAPPROPRIATE.
THE REMAINING 30 PERCENT SAID
I'M A BETTER LOOKING VERSION OF
PIERCE BROSNAN.
I'LL TAKE IT.
AS JOHN NOLTE POINTS OUT THE
SURVEY SHOWS HISPANICS OPINIONS
ARE NOT THAT DIFFERENT FROM
EVERYONE ELSE'S.
WHITE AMERICANS FELT THE POLICY
IS APPROPRIATE FOR A SIMILAR
MARGIN THAT'S GOT A SURPRISE TH
FOLKS AT POLITICO.
NOT YOU ARE ME, WE KNOW THAT
COMMON SENSE KNOWS NO BORDERS O
PIGMENT.
SENDING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO T
SANCTUARY CITIES HE BOASTED OF
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO EMBRACE OF
THEM THAT MAKES TOTAL SENSE.
AFTER ALL, WHAT COULD BE WRONG
WITH GIVING PEOPLE WHAT THEY'RE
ASKING FOR?
AT LEAST THAT'S WHAT I TELL
LARRY KUDLOW.
IT'S A FUNNY, I KNEW HARDER WAS
A TERRIBLE SAFE WORD.
WHICH IS WHY IT'S SO WEIRD TO
SEE THE LEFT-WING CITIES WORK
WITH AT LIGHTNING SPEED TO
DEPORT THE MIGRANTS.
IF THEY ONLY USE THE SAME SPEED
TO GIVE AND HE FED BLM AND
OUTSIDERS THE BOOT DURING THE
RIOTS, THEY EVEN CALLED IN THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
LAST TIME PEOPLE LIVING ON AN
ISLAND ISLAND OVERREACTED THAT
MUCH, A SHARK HAD EATEN THE
KICKER BOY.
EVEN IN JOBS, THEY THAT THE
SHARKING OUT FOR A WEEK.
IT'S OLD NEWS TO YOU.
AT THE LIVER WAS BACK THE
POLICIES AS LONG AS THEY DON'T
TO DEAL WITH THEM.
AGAIN, IT'S NOT IN MY BACKYARD.
UNLESS YOU MOWING IT.
THEY DID THIS WITH CRIME.
TO GET PRIVATE SECURITY AND LIV
IN GATED COMMUNITIES.
WHY NOT DEFEND THE POLICE?
WHEN I EMPTIED THE PRESENCE?
IT'S EASY TO SQUINT THERE ARE
TOO MANY PEOPLE BEHIND BARS WHE
YOU'RE SCREAMING IT FROM BEHIND
YOUR OWN.
AFTER SERVING AS A MAGNET FOR
MIGRANTS, THERE WANT NOTHING TO
DO WITH THEM.
THEY KICKED THEM TO THE CURB
THAT LIKELY HAD A CAPRIO'S
GIRLFRIEND ON THE 20TH BIRTHDAY.
SHE SHE'S GETTING UP THERE.
START WALKING SLOWER.
THEY'RE LIKE THAT ONE PERSON AT
WORK WHO BOASTS ABOUT
VOLUNTEERING AT THE SOUP KITCHE
ONCE, FIVE YEARS AGO.
AND THEN WE'LL NEVER LET YOU
FORGET IT.
BUT WHEN YOU ASK OF THEM FOR
FAVOR, THEY'RE TOTALLY SWAMPED.
BACK TO THE POLE.
IT TELLS YOU SOMETHING WE'VE
ALSO SAID FOR YEARS.
THE MIGRANTS FROM DOWN SOUTH AR
MORE LIKE YOU THAT THEY ARE LIK
THE LEFT.
SERIOUSLY.
IF YOU HAVE MORE IN COMMON WITH?
THE HISPANIC EYE THAT OUT TO FI
YOUR CABLE OR SETH MEYERS?
THE WOMAN WHO CLEANS YOUR HOTEL
ROOM OR SUNNY HOLLISTON
ORIS SHOULD I SAY HOSTILE?
THE GUY WHO DELIVERS YOUR PISA
O'BRIEN STELTER?
OKAY.
AND THEY ARE NOW THE SAME GUY,
BUT YOU GET IT.
LOVE YOU, BRIAN.
I AM HERE FOR YOU.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY
WANT TO BE IN AMERICA BUT THAT
THAT'S PART OF IT.
I THINK IT'S TIME TO HEAR FROM
SOMEONE STUPID.
THAT'S WHAT'S SO INTERESTING FO
ME THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
LATINOS THAT VOTE REPUBLICAN
BECAUSE THEY VOTE AGAINST THEIR
SELF-INTEREST.
IF YOU ARE REALLY INTERESTED IN
THESE TYPES OF ISSUES AND THAT
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT
YOU ARE SO SMART, SUNNY.
YOU KNOW SO MUCH MORE THAN THEM.
WHAT AN ARROGANT BIGOT.
I HATE TO TELL YOU YOU CANNOT
DEFINED THEIR SELF INTEREST IF
YOU WERE SPOT AT THE SELF AND
THE INTEREST.
WHAT ISSUES ARE YOU INTERESTED
ANYWAY THAT THEY COULD POSSIBLY
CARE ABOUT?
I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER MET A
WOKE MEXICAN OR A WOKE
VENEZUELAN OR A WOKE CUBAN.
MANY HAVE EXPERIENCED THE
CONSEQUENCES OF LEFTISM OF
LOCALISM AND IT LIKE A
SANITATION TRUCK AND A 90-DEGRE
DAY, THEY CAN SMELL THAT GARBAG
AND MILE AWAY.
AND IT LIKE OUR COLLEGE KIDS,
YOU'LL SEE CARLOS JUNIOR WEARIN
A CHAKE WHETHER A T-SHIRT
BECAUSE HIS PARENTS WOULD HAVE
BEAT HAS BUT LIKE A CONGA DRUM.
I DOUBT ANY CENTRAL AMERICAN
WITH A TRANSACT OF US TELL THEM
WHAT SAID YOU KNOW AND WHAT'S A
NINA I DOUBT ANY GUATEMALAN WIL
EMBRACE GENDER AFFIRMATION
SEARCH OF A THEIR KIDS I DOUBT
ANY EMIGRANT THINGS YOU CAN
REPLACE FOSSIL FUELS WITH
WINDMILLS AND THEN BURKE STEALS
BUT THAT'S THE LEFT SUNNY.
IT'S NO WONDER HISPANICS ARE
RUNNING FROM YOU LIKE YOUR COVI
WITH A COLD SORE.
HOWEVER, HERE'S ONE PERSON WHO
GETS IT.
>> IMMIGRATION HAS TRULY NEVER
BEEN A TOUGH ISSUE FOR LATINOS.
THE METHODS IF YOU TALK ABOUT
MIGRANTS IF YOU SHOW THESE
STORIES THE LATINOS WILL VOTE
FOR YOU.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THEY CARE ABOUT ECONOMY AND
CRIME AND JOBS AND EDUCATION.
THAT THAT SET LATINOS ARE
SENDING A MESSAGE THEY ARE
DRIFTING AWAY THEY'RE WALKING
AWAY FROM THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> THIS SHIFT SHOULD NOT BE THE
REASON WHY YOU SHOULD EMBRACE
IMMIGRATION.
YOU SHOULD EMBRACE IT BECAUSE
IMMIGRANTS ARE US AND IT NOT IN
THE OLD-FASHIONED IN THE BELIEV
MUCH OF SAME THINGS.
THAT CONTENT IS IN THE CHARACTE
AND CHARACTER IS FOUND IN HARD
WORK AND THAT THERE SHOULD BE N
LINE CUTTING COMING IN.
WE LOVE PROCESS, LIKE THE
PROCESS TALK TO ANY ÉMIGRÉ TO
BUILD OUT THE FORMS AWAITED AND
LINES AND WAITED YEARS TODAY
THEY SOUND LIKE REAGAN
REPUBLICANS AT MINUS THE KHAKIS.
BUT DEMS DON'T SEE THEM.
THEY JUST SEE BOATS.
AND IT LIKE BIDEN AFTER HUMAN
SET OF METAMUCIL, THEY REALLY
COULDN'T GIVE A BLEEP.
THAT ALWAYS GETS THE APPLAUSE.
TO OUR FRIENDS WHO VALUE FAMILY
RESPECT AND HARD WORK, WELCOME
AND WHEN STS THEY MIGHT NOT OUR
THAT'S BEEN YOUR BUT WE HAVE A
PLACE IN AMERICA SOMEWHERE FOR
YOU.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
SHE GAVE DC A CASE OF PTSD.
KAYLEE MEGAN ANY
HE'S HAD IT MORE HIGH-PROFILE
GAS AND JEFFREY EPSTEIN'S ISLAND
.
DAVE RUBEN.
LIKE A HIGHWAY IN THE WINTER,
SHE'S GOT TO COLD SHOULDERS AND
WAS LIKELY WRECK CAR.
HE SO LARGE PEOPLE ASSUME HIS
PRONOUNS ARE FEE BY BOAT AND
FOUL.
CONGRATULATIONS ARE IN ORDER,
MR. RUBIN.
YOU WERE RINGING THE BELL
YESTERDAY AND IT WAS IN SOME
CLUB.
>> THAT WAS LATER IN THE DAY BU
I THINK THE BELGIAN TALKING
ABOUT.
RING THE BELL FOR RUMBLE WHICH
IS IT NOW TOTALLY PUBLIC AND
FREE SPEECH IS PUBLIC AND WE AR
GOING TO BEAT BE YOUTUBE AND
GOOGLE AND FACEBOOK AND TWITTER.
AND ALL OF THAT STUFF.
AND, GREG, YOU HAD A GOOD YOU'R
NUMBER ONE IN THE NIGHT.
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT YOU BU
IT'S IMPORTANT I MENTIONED YOU
DID NOT INVEST WHEN I ASKED YOU.
YEAH, YOU COULD BE PRETTY RICH
RIGHT NOW.
>> I ALSO WOULD NOT HAVE A JOB.
AND WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO WOR
AT ANOTHER MEDIA COMPANY.
>> YOU WOULDN'T NEED A JOB.
THERE'S A GREAT LITTLE GIG
YOU'VE GOT HERE.
IT'S GOOD IT'S KEEPING UP.
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF I WANT
TO TALK TO YOU ANYMORE.
WE YOU SURPRISED BY THE POLE?
>> NO.
OF COURSE NOT.
IT'S TIME FOR THE LATINOS TO
LEAD THE DEMOCRATS IT'S TIME FO
THE GAYS TO LEAD THEM IT'S TIME
FOR EVERYONE TO LEAVE THE
DEMOCRATS PERIOD.
THERE IS NOTHING THEY ARE.
HAD THERE IS NOTHING LEFT.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE THAT ONE SHO
THAT IS TO BRING JFK BACK FROM
THE DEAD.
THAT WOULD PRETTY MUCH IT BE AT
AND UNTIL THEY DO THAT YOU'RE
EITHER IN A CRAZY PARTY OR I
WOULD CALL IT TO SANITY PARTY
BECAUSE IT HAS SOMETHING TO DO
WITH DESANTIS AND THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH REPUBLICANS RIGHT
NOW.
>> THERE YOU GO.
A REANIMATED JFK.
IN THIS CASE STACY WOULD BE
HAPPY BECAUSE HE DOESN'T NEED A
HEARTBEAT.
>> THAT JAKE JOE COMPANY MUST I
MAKES NO SENSE.
>> IT MAY MADE NONSENSE AT AT
OSCAR MIKE AND I REITERATE HOW
RICH YOU WOULD BE?
YOU WHAT HAVE TO MAKE SENSE.
>> I'LL TELL YOU THE NUMBER
LATER DOES THAT NUMBER BEGIN
WITH A B.
>> YOU WOULD BE DOING ALRIGHT.
I'M GOING TO IGNORE YOUR FOR TH
REST OF THE SHOW.
KAYLEE, HOW FAR ALONG?
>> SEVEN MONTHS.
>> I WILL GIVE YOU EXTRA TIME
BECAUSE YOU'LL BE COMMENTING FO
ACUTE ISCHEMIC HEART BEATING FO
TWO DNA FOR TWO.
IT.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS POLE
?
>> IT'S NOT SURPRISING.
AT THE LEFT MAKES A CARICATURE
OF LATINOS.
IF YOU ARE LATINO, YOU MUST CAR
ABOUT THE BORDER.
WHEN I HAD THE UNFORTUNATE
DISTINCTION OF BEING COLLEGE
WITH BRIAN STELTER, THEY USED T
SAY TO ME WHEN TRUMP WAS RUNNIN
FOR THE NOMINATING AND 2020 THI
IS POLITICS OF ADDITION AND
SUBTRACTION AND THE SKY
SUBTRACTING ALL THE LATINOS OUT.
AS IT TURNS OUT, HE INCREASED A
THE PARTY'S MARGIN AND 2016.
IN 2020 AND MIAMI-DADE COUNTY,
HE GOT THE HIGHEST ABOUT TOTAL
OF ANY REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE IN
16 YEARS.
WHY?
HE WAS UP THERE CHATTING BELL
THAT WALL.
BUT IT'S BECAUSE HE DIDN'T TREA
LATINOS LIKE A CARICATURE.
THEY WANT BREAKFAST TACOS.
THEY WANT AS ONE TEXAS BLOGGER
HIRED BY THE CONGRESSMAN HE
CALLED HER MS. FREE HOLDINGS
MISS BEADS ALIKE WOULD DEMOCRAT
HAVE A CHANCE, THEY IMMEDIATELY
GO TO THE RACE IS PLACED WHERE
THEY CHARACTERIZE AND
MARGINALIZE LATINOS AND THEY AR
NOTICING THAT AND THEY SAY THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY MAKES MORE
SENSE.
BUILD THAT WALL.
>> THE ONLY WOKE NEXT YEAR TO T
PEOPLE WHO ARE BORN HERE.
DO YOU SENSE THAT?
>> YOU HAVE TO BE BORN AND
SPOILED.
IT'S A CAVEAT.
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE FIRST WORLD
PROBLEMS LIKE MY PHONE IS AT 30
PERCENT.
>> THAT DOES.
I GET PRETTY UPSET.
>> I HATE WHEN THAT LITTLE RED
THING COMES ON.
>> I NEVER GET TWO THAT POINT A
THAT'S DANGEROUS.
>> YOU CAN ACTUALLY FEEL IT
PHYSICALLY IN YOUR POCKET.
NOT A FIRST WORLD PROBLEM.
THE POLE IT AT THE ARGUMENT
ITSELF IS RACIST.
IT'S STUPID.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO CAR
ABOUT GOING TO A SANCTUARY CITY
AS THE PEOPLE ON THE BUS AND
THAT WE DON'T SEE THEM WRITING
SPANISH TOO HELP NOTES ON THE
WINDOW.
THEY ARE NOT ON THE BUS GOING NO
.
THEY'RE FINE WHERE THEY ARE
GOING.
THAT'S LIKE TELLING ME HEY JUST
SO YOU KNOW WATERMELON IS FINE
THIS YEAR IN THE SUMMER.
ASSUMING THAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT
IT BECAUSE I'M BLACK.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
IT LATINOS ARE WITH THAT.
WHY THE ONLY ONE THAT HAS TO BE
OKAY WITH IT IS THE IMMIGRANT.
PERIOD.
>> CAT, WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I AM NOT COMMENTING FOR TWO.
I THINK AT ONE RIGHT HERE
NOTHING IN MY WOMB.
I THINK WHAT SONNY SAID WAS
EXTREMELY INSULTING ACTUALLY.
YOUR SELF-INTEREST THE BEST
PERSON WHO KNOWS WHAT IT IS IS
IT YOUR SELF AND THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE DIFFERENT VALUES THAN SHE
DOES BUT WHAT SHE IS SAYING WHE
SHE SAYS THAT IS I KNOW BETTER
THAN YOU DO.
THAT IS THE MOST DISRESPECTFUL
THING YOU CAN SAY TO ANOTHER
PERSON THAT THEY ARE TOO STUPID
TO KNOW WHAT'S GOOD FOR THEM.
I'VE NEVER MET YOU BUT I'M SO
SMART AND YOUR SADDAM AND THAT
THIS COMPASSIONATE TAKE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU'VE EVER REAC
THE FACT THAT ANYTHING OTHER
THAN MAKING DECISIONS FOR
YOURSELF IS COMPASSIONATE.
IT'S MEAN AND ARROGANT.
>> IT REALLY IS EXCELLENT POIN